it's almost hard to remember just how
restricted life was back in may 2020
social contact was severely limited
this is how arthur saw his
great-grandchildren
he had terminal cancer the children's
mother a midwife who was afraid she'd
bring covid back from the hospital we
had to stand outside his home
and and then
talk to him through the window
and
unfortunately uh they never got the
chance to actually touch him again or
hug him again before he died it's been
really difficult for us all and so to
see
images of people who weren't following
the rules who weren't making every
effort to keep people safe in the way
that we felt we were
has been
it felt like a betrayal
this is the image that's led people to
look back on what they were missing out
on
in the same month that the prime
minister his wife and downing street
staff gathered in the garden
georgia was at her mum's funeral
tracy died of cancer aged just 50.
georgia had to say goodbye with just 10
people there all this stuff's come out
it's just makes you think
you know why
why did we have to lose out on not being
you know not being able to hook my
grandma you know who lost a daughter
just because while he was doing all of
this it's just a bit
it is really really frustrating
obviously it's not just me in the
situation
paul pryor also lost his dad david that
month
just didn't get a chance to say goodbye
properly and then the funeral
there was no wake
only 14 people there they have loads of
friends from the fire service and
whatever else so
it wasn't great
on sky news the deputy prime minister
insisted the gathering was a staff
meeting
it's a place of work they're all in
suits um or predominantly in uh informal
type and sometimes as in many work
situations particularly given the
pressures that the number 10 team are
under they might have
a drink
after the formal business has ended
they weren't in suits but stan and janet
would have loved a party for his 90th
unfortunately we were resorted to
standing at the end of the drive and
waving and um singing happy birthday
from a distance which was a real shame
and ironically there's probably nothing
that my my grandfather would have
enjoyed more than sitting in the garden
with a glass of wine and some cheese
with all of us the sadness the sacrifice
the sheer difficulty of life back in may
2020
brought into sharp focus by an image
that's angered many
becky johnson sky news